thank you very much thanks for being
here my name is Jeremy smart I'm the
editor of cranes New York business with
me today is Gary Vaynerchuk CEO of
vaynermedia a host of the askgaryvee
show champion head coach of vaynernation
Jets fan hi heart Jets fan we're just
we're just gonna roll here and talk
about basically how to win in social
marketing social media online deliver
value to your customers figure out the
future solve the world's problems maybe
we won't go that far but Gary how do you
you're a very use that you have high EQ
yes so had it first of all how do you
know that about yourself and to what
extent is self-knowledge important for
people who are going out there and in
prospecting or selling or you know
starting a business so I think I know
that about myself because having high EQ
means having self-awareness and so just
it's a loop right it's something that
it's something that I think I think it's
the reason I think I have high EQ is
because I have such low IQ and I'm so
over indexing and success that it makes
me think that that's what it must be so
you put yourself out there you're out
there all the time your schedule is like
you wake up at 6 you work out you hang
with your kids and then you're off and
done until midnight what are you doing
you know it's a lot of different things
these days I'm spending an enormous
amount of time being the CEO of
vaynermedia I also am the general
partner of a fund vayner/rse it's a
twenty five million dollar seed fund so
I'm investing we've made 76 investments
you know to kiss 76 frogs you've got to
look at a couple thousands so that's a
lot you know I do the show I I engage
with my fan base I I do a lot of this
kind of stuff and so you know I'm
keeping myself very busy I do a ton of
pay forward prospecting taking random
meetings that come in my inbox and I'm
doing a lot of stuff you know for me all
my behavior maps 2 3 5 7 12 15 year
thinking vs.
three six twelve month thinking and so
I'm doing a lot of hedging investing
trying to play the second and third
chess move which creates a very
different day in the life right you're
doing branding which is bringing
awareness here you're meeting with
seventeen year olds with wild ideas just
in case at 24 that idea you know that
idea is not wild anymore and she can
apply that to a real business so I'm a
best thing and I'm investing in myself
as an operator and investing in
companies I want to get back to that in
a minute but first let's start with your
business your current business
vaynermedia yeah but you started in 2009
yes and that was sort of a great time to
get into social media it was sort of
really the marketing side was just
taking off yeah if you started it today
yeah what would you do differently what
would be the challenge more opportunity
harder now I see where you're going with
that question right you know um you know
I think if you're good you win in any
market right I don't think vaynermedia
is successful because we were early as a
matter of fact for a lot of people here
that no I didn't even really get
involved into vain in vain or media
until really 2012 I was still you know I
wrote crush it my first book that went
very viral for me and and that kept me
very busy I was still running a 60
million dollar a year wine business in
New Jersey called Wine Library and that
was also back in the day when I answered
every single tweet and that took up five
to seven hours a day so Vanner media
really didn't take my attention until
2000 September of 2011 and you know and
so I mean if you look at the growth of
vaynermedia from 2000 May 2009 to
September 11 2011 we had a 25-person
company from September 2011 to now in
that three plus years we've grown from
30 to 500 so I've been operating that
for the last four right so it sounds
like what you're saying is you're just
thinking you're wasting the time I'm
saying I'm question directly if you're
great at what you do the market could be
beginning it could be massively
challenging I truly believe the cream
always rises to the
top and so if you're good enough you
could start a social digital agency
tomorrow and if you out execute
everybody because tomorrow there's a
snapchat at a Yik yak and tomorrow
there's a meerkat and a periscope and
there's always something to latch on if
you want to sell that or what about just
driving results I mean [ __ ] in 2009
people didn't know what I was talking
about it's nice that Facebook's at scale
and you can actually have an audience
and people actually in corporate America
think that this might this thing might
be something the other thing is really
defining social media I mean I I truly
think social media is a slang term for
the current state of the internet right
it's just the word we use to talk about
the internet right now just like we used
web 2.0 to talk about it just a couple
minutes ago I mean go google it right
now Facebook was referred to as a web
2.0 company not a social media company
and so we need terms to like get us all
online then marketing talk and I think
it's really easy to dismiss social media
as a driver for business it's a lot
harder to dismiss the current state of
the internet and so that's fascinating
to me so how do you execute on social
media and and how are those skillsets
evolving or changing I think you you
execute on social media the way you
execute on traditional media you reverse
engineer what you're trying to
accomplish so whether you're buying an
ad and cranes or USA Today or running a
television commercial or a radio ad or a
billboard or a banner or an email
marketing campaign it's just all the
same which is reverse-engineer what you
want the sale the awareness the the data
filling out whatever you're trying to
achieve use the tools in the ecosystem
that best allow you to do that for
example if you want to do direct
response or conversion based marketing
or get an action right somebody to sign
up for something somebody to buy a
bottle of wine you do that on Facebook
Facebook has the ad product that can
actually get that done if you want
branding and the attention of the end
consumer so people know what you're up
to you do that on Instagram because
right now if you're lucky enough to
build a following on Instagram everybody
in this audience carefully looks through
their Instagram because we've all
learned not to follow everybody because
we made those mistakes on Twitter and so
now if you're actually following
somebody on insta
you really care and so my strategies
would be different based on what my
outcome needs to be right if I want to
build long tail lifetime value loyalty I
love Twitter because I can jump into
somebody's conversation and go back and
forth six or seven times and build a
little bit of depth it's not just me
pushing out content you know and it
changes right if I want to do video
storytelling 10 seconds ago it was only
YouTube now I think Facebook videos
especially with the targeting has
outrageous capabilities to really matter
and so you know another thing you want
to sell stuff I think the biggest open
space right now is to do a QVC like show
on meerkat or periscope I think it would
dominate so I would consider that you
know the Pinterest is insane Pinterest
is basically Google Images right like
you know people Pinterest is a search
engine then people see what they want
visually then they click it and then
they come to you I mean it's an
incredible platform for direct response
and branding you know look I I'm super
aware of my personality like how I go
but like I'm a practitioner like while
everybody else is debating about this
[ __ ] I'm using it and I use it every
single day and I've learned every aspect
of it and that gives me a 360 view of it
mm-hmm
and you talk about that so going to your
VC funding hat yes when you're looking
at all these perspective ideas and and
startups you mentioned the other day you
know everyone's got ideas as execution
so how do you when somebody comes to you
with an idea and I know a lot of people
do we're just standing outside and we
had like three people come up to you and
sort of just do the insta pitch like how
do you know whether their idea is gonna
work and or how do you know that they
can execute how do you establish that
it's gotten harder when I first got into
it my first three investments were
Facebook Twitter and Tumblr right yeah
so you know and then when I think about
like or I wrote the first check into
Birchbox another great wind they all
have different stories the truth is I
look like a hero now but Facebook
Twitter and Tumblr were further along F
Williams was
bet on he'd already sold and built
blogger and he was right about ODL and
podcasting it's just that iTunes came
along and that scale that was really not
gonna let that business to succeed you
know you you know the answer is you
don't now because so many of the things
that I'm being pitched are kids fresh
out of school who you know are very
young and you don't know and you know
I've projected so much of a hustle
salesman mentality a lot of people know
my spiel so they try to sell against
that like I'm gonna work 24 hours a day
and so to me it's the mix between the
jockey and the horse right am i betting
on him or his idea once in a while ideas
are in a place run like crap that's such
a good idea
to me I could be wrong but I'd like to
learn more about that so even if I lose
because actually the the dude seems a
little bit like a schlemiel but [ __ ] it
I'm gonna I'm gonna bet because I want
to learn this space and I'm gonna keep
it close and I may use that IP somewhere
else that might be a bet sometimes I'll
bet just on the jockey because I'm like
you know she's gonna kill it this idea
kind of sucks but she's gonna be pumped
with me as an investor in this and all
invested and on best and invest and so
those are some of the strategies and
what if you don't have your personality
what if you're more IQ than EQ is is the
key surrounding yourself with people who
have that and what if you don't have the
budget for that what's your yeah I mean
look I'll be honest with you I'm not
pumped that I'm over the top I like
people think my personality is my weapon
I have a lot of work to do to get you
know when I curse appear and I have
nothing but ego and bravado like that
turns off plenty of people I have a ton
of work to do to fix how I communicate
when there's a lot of people I'm a hell
of a lot calmer if it's one-on-one then
you give me this and I'm struggling I
can't help it like sorry like my
chemicals are [ __ ] excited you know
and so you know I am you know everybody
thinks my personality or it's common
thought that my personality is this
great thing and it does listen it works
for a lot of people but it also doesn't
work for a lot of people and it actually
doesn't work for a lot of people that
are in very important places usually the
establishment that I feel is vulnerable
to the current state of the situation so
you know one I would say if you
are more IQ more reserved like [ __ ]
you're lucky right - you've got to just
be self-aware that that's your strength
and you need to bet on that like my IQ
no you can't look you in the eye people
at vaynermedia I love them especially if
they stay in their Lane and crush it and
try to really focus on the quant and the
math and all the things they bring to
the table you know it's really awkward
when the person that doesn't look you in
the eye tries to be the life of the
party
you know and so I think that I think
it's I think it's people are not betting
on their strengths enough America as a
culture is very good at selling us the
things we need to fix and I'm a very
very big proponent and I mean all in on
the thesis of take a step back assess
yourself and bet on what you've
naturally got your upside is much higher
there than to try to fix all your
weaknesses I just believe in that you
know I really do I think the people that
we revere like in culture they're the
ones that most bet on their strengths at
an early age like LeBron didn't give a
[ __ ] about science class you know and it
worked out okay for me it worked out
okay for him right and so and there's a
lot of versions of that and I actually
think entrepreneurship is that way I
think it's much more of a natural skill
than people realize and I think that's
the product that I'm struggling with
right now people think that starting a
company is a rite of passage right now
because there's so much money being
thrown out there and it's very hard
right now to navigate through and make
these bets because it's just everybody
just thinks they're an entrepreneur
right that easy
yeah you've been talking about that
lately sort of the glut the bubble there
will be you think there will be a
reckoning right you always uh-huh I mean
always I'm really bad at picking when
that reckoning is in 2009 when I started
vaynermedia I'm like another 24 months
and this bubble is gonna [ __ ] burst I
mean I mean it's ATX that bubble so
right I'm not good at that but it will
happen and what will survive what will
die the same thing this is you know this
is not me being smart this is
well-documented what will survive are
people that are real operators and
understand what the hell they're doing
and are building businesses that are not
predicated on raising
round and the ones that will fail as
soon as there's no money and you're
burning your cash and you've got four
months to live and you have no money
coming in and there's no money available
you're at a [ __ ] business and so a
lot of people are building that game
because they're building towards
momentum another round another round and
then an exit or we'll figure it out
those are the vulnerable business so
that seems to be the culture I don't
know if it's just the media or if it's
the VC culture of get to that next round
you know steady growth steady growth
because of BC's playing a game of just
one unicorn and it pays the whole game
they're actually right
VCS are pushing all these young
entrepreneurs in the right direction
because if one breaks who gives a [ __ ]
if you failed on the other hundred your
ROI is so intense on that one uber on
that one Facebook that it makes the math
work so it's in their best interest to
push everybody towards that behavior
they don't they're managing a portfolio
they're managing a portfolio they don't
care and what if you actually do
something smart that works that they can
apply and help and give advice to the
thing that is a little further along
they're managing a portfolio right and
so that they're giving the advice that's
best in their interest and what it's and
good entrepreneurs can separate advice
that's in someone else's best interest
and take the advice that's in their best
right so as a VC switching on yes yeah
would you advise against taking VC money
ah yeah if you can help it like like
we're in a weird culture right now like
we're celebrating giving up pieces of
your business hey we raised four million
dollars awesome we gave up 30% of our
business
let's go like it's a great it's a crazy
thing to celebrate now I get it
there might not be any alternative but
you understand for me building from zero
is very attractive like you you learn a
lot of things you you like you know it's
nice to not be reliant on those kind of
things like I love building from zero I
think it's super attractive it forces
you to learn how to make money which I
don't know you know we're dynamic and
business that's part of the oxygen you
know and so I think that I think if you
can do it and then somebody will argue
and somebody can raise their hand say
yeah but some things need are capital
intensive and like cool of course but
you can also go find a rich partner you
could also have a side hustle you could
also do it from 7:00 p.m.
two in the morning it won't happen in
one hour the lack of patience in our
society right now will be the death to
95% of the businesses that are in play
right now lack of patience is the
vulnerability in the marketplace right
now everybody wants everything fast
not your fault we're just humans and the
world got fast but I struggle when I see
a 24 year old when I'm like [ __ ] you
have so much time you know and like and
like if they just real like and by the
way I was that person that's why you
know you get older and get the gray
hairs you lose a little bit like [ __ ] if
I realized how much time I had as a
businessman you know how pumped I am I'm
not an athlete at 35 you're finished
right as a business person like you know
my business partner my funds Steve Ross
he's just turned 75 like he's on fire
I'm like I try to surround myself with
60 70 80 90 year old entrepreneurs and
business people because it just makes me
feel good of how much time I have to
keep playing yeah it's a lifelong
pursuit and by the way if you play the
long game
your behavior sets you up better for the
long game and you know unless you die
you'll be there for the long game and so
it's I'm very fascinated by everybody's
behavior for the short term in a world
where you actually live and see three
years from now what behavior surprises
you specifically or I think uh ton of
people sell too early you know uh I I
was on CNN the day Instagram sold for a
billion dollars friend and Piers Morgan
said what do you think and I said I
think Facebook's stolen I get out of the
studio and you remember all your own
thoughts on the Instagram 1 billion
dollar purchase 551 days in I thought it
was a I thought a billion dollars not
bad you know I got out of the office
there was thousands of people who you
know obviously CNN's a big platform a
lot of people not my fans just drilling
me calling me an idiot and I saved all
those tweets and and when Facebook
bought whatsapp for 19 billion you know
a lot of the conversation said huh you
know maybe instrument was a decent deal
and then when the bankers come out
recently and say it's worth 40 billion
so after that one came out and went back
one afternoon and hit up a ton of the
people that said I was an idiot
and replied on Twitter and said what now
[ __ ] so that's what you mean by the
long game and that's the game I mean I
think people saw that as like incredibly
good you know and I thought like I
thought Facebook did incredibly well I
was a huge proponent of Facebook buying
snapchat for three billion I thought it
was a steal again everybody freaked out
like what the [ __ ] now if you really
understand what's happening snapchats
the only true only true vulnerability to
Facebook game which is let's use our day
data to layer on top of everybody's
attention well the problem is everybody
under 22 and under 18 and under all of
them are snapchat first and Facebook
can't layer under there and that
attention attention my friends is the
asset attention is the asset before you
can tell me how great your business is
or how much I should buy your product or
your service or read my story before you
can do that you need my attention just
to have the abet to tell you about the
thing that is the asset that is the
asset and if you can figure out how to
play in the attention graph you win it's
not about impressions it's not about
numbers its depth not with write the the
catch word now is engagement and
everybody's trying and that's as a
journalist that's good news for me
because I figure hey I'm gonna write
great stories and people are gonna read
them and then you know do your thing
with the ads on the side as long as you
guys know how to communicate in the
modern world to create a gateway drug
version of your long-form content
because the problem with attention is
the supply and demand of it and
everybody here is super busy right like
I think my competitor I truly think my
only competitor in business is your
index finger I'm scared shitless of this
because that's the game now this is not
the second screen this is the first
second third fourth fifth and sixth
screen then comes magazine or television
right this is it and the competition for
your attention because everything is
stream dynamics now right because it's
the context of the unit that delivers
information this is my competitor this
[ __ ] thing so you talked about sort
of
channeling your need or purpose to the
right medium where is their value is
there are their undervalued areas that
you should be spending on in terms of
spot you know sponsoring your posts or
ever creating content distributing it
yeah yeah I think the number one
underrated place on the internet for
that is Facebook and I think that
smiling I'm smiling because I know how
many people don't think that uh-huh
because I don't think people are
practitioners I don't think they know
what they're talking about I think the
headline read and they read at age or
TechCrunch and at your organic drop
reaches down and I got like like somehow
advertising one wasn't always the way
that you got your content distributed
like like somehow that Facebook wants
money for distribution is some crazy
thing it's crazy because it started as
organic reach I get it but like how else
are you getting your message out when
you're a company you're buying Google
AdWords you're buying banners you're
buying all traditional media that all
costs money for distribution so it you
know I think Facebook is insanely
undervalued
I think Instagram is SuperDuper
interesting because just the depth of
attention is extraordinary
I think Pinterest is incredible I'm a
very very bullish on Pinterest how do
you convert Instagram to sales because
that's a challenge or you that you
convert Instagram into sales from
branding not sales uh-huh got it so
Instagram has to play like print and
outdoor media it has to just like that's
incredible and it's an emotion there's
such a big difference between branding
and marketing and sales and everybody
convolute them right you've got the DR
people who are like [ __ ] Instagram
because all they want is quant math it's
SEO its SEM its banner its Facebook dark
posts just math right get them into
funnel but Zynga and Groupon play that
game and if you don't build brand you
become vulnerable right and then there's
the people that are just like fashion
brands who are like this inspires the
world [ __ ] that you know like if nobody
sees it you're dead and so there's a mix
and you've got to have both if you want
if you want to be big if you want to be
big you need to understand both branding
and marketing and sales if you want cash
you need to understand sales right if
you if you want cash you need to
understand say
so that's the breakdown okay and if
you're spending money on Facebook what's
the message there how do you how are you
tailoring that message how is that well
that's the best part that's why I love
it so much you're tailoring it
individually like if you were if you're
a woman and work in a corporation like I
know what to say to you right if you're
an entrepreneur I know what to say to
you like the fact that I can break down
you know 27 to 29 year old females that
were born in Korea that love the Houston
Rockets
and there's 14,000 of those people like
we've never it is it's great listen
literally let me tell you what I'm about
to do
coming off stage I'm literally gonna
walk out of here right now get in the
cab and buy more Facebook stock every
time I do a talk that is it's stunning
to me how good of an ad product it is
and then the number one thing that I'm
excited about in the world is that
journalists continue to write about the
kids aren't on there they're all on
Instagram and snapchat organic reaches
the longer the non-practitioners
of the world which aka 98% of the market
continue to talk about it
the longer I have time this is SEO all
over again ty built Wine Library 2000
2001 2002 but really there's no ROI and
SEO my cool you're right and then come
into the office every day and [ __ ]
sell 40 thousand dollars worth of wine
for eight cents a click you know and so
email marketing it's all the same game
it's arbitrage where is their attention
where is there a new ad form to
storytellin sell in there and where has
the whole market not come because
marketers ruin everything it's just you
have to make your money in between the
time that users are there and the
marketers get there that's the action
we've got about two minutes left the
next big thing you like to scroll down
the most popular apps and tell you you
wish you can tell me I wish I didn't
tell you ah yeah I well you did you told
everybody yeah and the good news is I
tell everybody everything and I was
really setting up that statement by
telling you I wish I didn't tell you
because I want everybody here what I'm
about to say I talk about everything I
know for one reason 99% of you are gonna
do
think about it and it's the most
interesting thing to me ever the fact
that the information is commoditized if
you want to know how to be good at
anything right now it's there but
nobody's executing so yeah the way I
find the next big thing is every morning
when I wake up I take my phone and I go
directly to iTunes to top 150 apps and I
look at the free charts and that's how I
saw snapchat way early and that's how so
uqa early and it's nice a dub mash way
early like it just shows up it's just
one forty to one day out of nowhere I'm
like what's this thing and then the next
day it's still there 1:39 am i right
that's two days and that's there 129 I'm
like okay three days it wasn't just some
[ __ ] adspend
let me download it let me play let me
taste let me understand
let me project my EQ of what the
consumer behavior will be let me start
figuring it out let me start watching
people use it and how do you understand
when you when you when you try it out
well that's the thing I'm talented that
like that's why I got lucky that's why I
have the permission to sit here like my
career has been predicated on
understanding what they're gonna do
before they think they're gonna do it
mm-hmm I was right that they were gonna
be on Facebook when they said they
weren't I was right to say the Twitter
was cool when they said it was dumb [ __ ]
I was right to tell them that Instagram
was going to get older when they weren't
sure I was right when I said this ghost
thing called snapchat is real when they
didn't see it and so that's my game all
right well thank you for sharing that
game with us thanks guys gary vaynerchuk
you can check him out every day the
askgaryvee show
I'm Jeremy smirk rains Newark business
thanks for joining us thank you guys